programming cells Andrew Phillips and
his team at Microsoft are working on
ways to understand how cells make
decisions like those the trigger
cancerous growth which could ultimately
help create smarter drugs current
methods of drug discovery involve lab
based trial and error as experts tests
different chemical combinations against
a disease this is a hugely expensive and
time-consuming process but by applying
concepts of computer programming to
biological research we can create a
rigorous framework for triggering
actions within a cell eventually a
programming language could be created
that models the relationship between
biological components and could be used
to control the way a cell behaves the
researchers hope to eventually create
systems that can detect a worrisome
change in a cell like the early stages
of cancer and trigger a response that
will fight it the complexity of cells
and their ability to process information
has a lot in common with computers but
unlike computers they weren't created by
humans so better understanding how they
operate and how to program them will
truly be a moonshot effort